Todd is with us in Baton Rouge Louisiana
hey Todd how are you how you doing with
Randy better than I deserve how can I
help okay I've been listening to your
program for a couple years now and then
think I've been doing very well I'm
pretty much out of it I just sold my
house I got about $40,000 of equity my
question is what do I do with the equity
why did you why did you sell our house I
need a bigger house we had me and my
wife had twins we have two other kids
now we have four kids in the house we
needed a full bedroom so you said you're
pretty on the notch out of that what
does pretty much mean I have a vehicle
$15,000 on it mm-hmm but there's my
question my question is what do I do
with my equity sure household income
it's not 80 okay you can do what you
want to do you need to pay the truck off
and put less down on the house which
means you're going to be buying less
house because I don't want you to take
out more than a 15-year loan where the
payments more than 1/4 of your take-home
pay you've probably heard me say that or
you can sell the truck and more down on
the house because the house is more
important than the truck well it's a
main vehicle so we can really uh sell it
and buy something test like thank you
yeah but um yeah I can do that what's
more important I mean it's up to you
putting more down on the house or
driving that truck it's up to you but I
mean you're trying to move up in house
and with $40,000 down in Baton Rouge you
can get a pretty decent house and
$80,000 income you can get a decent
house on a 15-year fixed-rate or the
payment is no more than 1/4 of your
income or you can put $25,000 down pay
off your truck but the truck that's got
to go it's either gone because you sold
it or it's gone because you paid it off
no way I'm keeping that truck that
around a bicycle before I had a dead car
payment again absolutely ridiculous